they say there are five stages of grief  well i'd like to add one more revenge  as we know cruella deville is pretty  villainous  in this film we get to see how she  became the villain we know today  we're on the story is wholly original  in a different time period being in the  late 70s you have that glint in your eye  and what glenn one of the most fun  things to explore  is her creativity she is very good at  what she does designing  i want to make art and i want to make  travel  the character is so much fun and so kind  of intoxicating  once you put this wild black and white  hair and this incredible makeup and  these completely unique costumes on  you feel like cruella de vil the  villains are always kind of the fun ones  i'm starting to remember you have a bit  of an extreme side  [Music]  you